The team at PUggs is excited
to simplify the development
of their conversational experience
using Dialogflow CX.
Stick around to see it all in action.
♪ [music] ♪
Hi, I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this episode
of Deconstructing Chatbots,
we will help our friends at PUggs
create a conversational experience
for their customer support
using Dialogflow CX.
Before we dive into the console, though,
let's lay out our use case
requirements first.
We know that most of their user requests
are to order dog shoes,
so it makes sense to start
with the order flow first.
In this flow, we want to collect
order information from the user,
including the size
and the color of the shoes,
and then present a confirmation.
If the user confirms, we end the flow,
and if they want to edit the order,
then we gather the new size
and color from them,
and then place the order.
Now that we know what we are building,
let's head to Dialogflow CX console.
The easiest way is to get there
from the documentation.
Create a new project,
make sure you enable Billing,
and the Dialogflow API.
Then we go back
into the Dialogflow CX console
and click on the project we just created.
It prompts us to create an agent.
That's exactly what we want to do.
We name it, select the location
where we want to deploy it,
and the timezone, and the language,
and we're good to create.
Now, notice that within a project,
we can create multiple agents.
We have our Default Start Flow
with our Start page,
which comes with
the Default Welcome Intent.
So let's go ahead and test it.
At this point, all it does
is greet the user.
We want to create a Transition Route
from the Start page
that leads to the Order flow.
Create new Intent.
Let's name it and add
some training phrases.
Let's add some basic ones such as,
"I would like to place an order."
But we also need to add
some specific phrases with color.
Let's add "I want to buy
green shoes for my pup."
As soon as we add that,
notice that the color parameter
automatically gets created
with @sys.color Entity type.
And this color parameter
will be stored in the session for us
to access in other pages.
Also, since the user
has already provided the color,
our agent will not ask
for that information,
providing a more natural experience.
Now, let's add
another example with the size.
"Wanna get large shoes for my husky."
Now, we see that the large
is not automatically identified
as a parameter
because size is unique to PUggs use case.
So let's fix that.
But before we do that,
add a Transition to new Page
where we will collect
information and save it.
Let's go into Manage > Entity Types,
and then Create New.
Name it "size," and add small,
medium, large size in there
with some synonyms.
Now, while we are on the Manage tab,
let's go into the Intents
to see if we can add
our "size" parameter now.
Add one or two more examples
with both size and color
to add some variety.
Let's head over to our
Collect Information page
and add the Entry dialogue
to let the user know
that we will create
some more information now.
Then add the Parameter.
Size is a required parameter,
and if the user does not provide it,
we want to prompt them
with the Fulfillment here.
We repeat the same for color as well.
With that, we are ready to define
our Transition routes from this page.
And in this case, we don't need
to trigger an Intent.
All we need is to make sure
our Parameters are filled in.
So we look for the condition to match:
$page.params.status = FINAL
Once all the Parameters
are defined and collected,
which means both size
and color, in this case,
that's when the status will turn to FINAL.
This is also where we can match
other conditions,
such as if the $page.params.color = RED,
then send to a "sorry" page
because that color is not available
in the inventory.
Once the status equals FINAL,
condition is met.
We would route the user
to the new confirmation page.
In the confirmation page,
let's first add the Entry dialogue
to share what they have selected to buy.
We can access the Parameters
in the session by using the $ sign.
We don't have any Parameter
to add for this page.
For the Transition routes,
we want to have a "yes" and a "no" route.
For "yes" path, let's create a new Intent
and call it "confirmation.yes,"
and provide a few Training phrases
that indicate "yes."
Save the Intent and then add
the Transition page as "Success."
Do the same thing for "no" route.
Success page is easy at this point.
All we need to do is add
a nice Entry dialogue.
For the Transition route,
add "true" in the Condition
to force and select End Flow
as the Transition page.
Now, the Failure page.
We want to see if the user wants
to change their selection,
or they just don't want to buy today.
For that, we add the Entry dialogue.
And then add a Transition Route.
If they say "no,"
we just want to add
a GoodBye page, quite simple.
But if they say "yes,"
then we send them back
to the start of the Flow
to make their color
and size selections.
Now, let's test it.
That doesn't quite work.
And that's because the Parameters
are already filled.
We need to clear out the Parameters
before the state changes
to the Start page.
And we do that in the Parameter presets
in the yes Intent Transition
of the Failure page.
Let's test it again, and we see
that the Flow is all set.
Alright, so that was a lot.
We created the entire
Order Flow from scratch
by creating a bunch of pages.
We also learned how Intents,
Parameters, and Entities work
in conjunction with the Pages.
I am very excited for the next episode
where we will extend the PUggs
conversation experience further
by adding multiple Flows.
Until then, I look forward
to seeing your thoughts
on this episode in the comments below.
♪ [music] ♪